منذ فترة طويلة
جاء محارب عظيم إلى هذه القرية
وعهد إلى أسلافنا
برؤى حرب النجوم هذه ، وهي سلسلة من
الأفلام القصيرة تظهر المجرة بعيدًا من
خلال الرسوم المتحركة
اليابانية ، أثرت السينما اليابانية بشدة على
حرب النجوم الأصلية ،
وقدمت أفلام الرؤى التسعة تعبيرًا إبداعيًا إلى
سبعة  لقد ألهمت استوديوهات animé star wars بشكل عام
العديد من صانعي الأفلام
ورسامي الرسوم المتحركة والمبدعين في اليابان ، لذا
من الرائع أن
يتم تصدير شيء ما ثم
إعادة استيراده ، ونأمل أن تعرف أنه
سيتم تصديره مرة أخرى ، سيكون لديه هذا
الإبداع الرائع.  تبدو دائرة الحياة من
النهج إلى الاستوديوهات اليابانية ، يرجى
إخبارنا بوجهة نظرك الخاصة
وقصتك
في حرب النجوم آه المجرات ،
فهذه هي الطريقة التي بدأ بها المشروع هذه
فرصة لإعادة تعريف
نوع رواية قصص حرب النجوم التي يمكننا القيام
بها  تكون قادرًا على استكشاف أشياء مختلفة
، حيث
تتميز رؤى حرب النجوم القديمة والشريرة بأعضاء فريق التمثيل الصوتي
من أليسون بري  نيل باتريك
هاريس وجيمس هونغ لمشجعين مدى الحياة
جوردان فيشر لقد كنت من محبي حرب النجوم على
حد سواء الكنسي وغير
الحقيقي للأغلبية إن لم تكن حياتي كلها ،
لا أتذكر وقتًا كنت طفلاً
لم أكن أمارس فيه بعضًا  سيف ضوئي مؤقت
من نوع ما أقبل هذه
المسؤولية
في هوليوود ، أنا ريك داماجيلا